is there a particular moment where you
started to feel like a source of
confidence like
like i'm here and i'm doing it i'm doing
it with momentum
i i i would say actually um
working on takers films because you know
talk about bringing people who looked
like us to the screen you know
taika did it you know he he um
he very much placed uh
our people our culture you know in the
in the front and center
um yeah and and i think that's
you know for me it was yeah working on
those stories
that he he told um
yeah it was a it was a big deal it felt
great to be a part of yeah whale writer
was quite an extraordinary shoot
we were in that community
um on the east coast uh and
it you know so much of what you see
in that film was very
present you know and like we were we'd
sit there and and
and you know nikki would be filming and
there'd be scenes
filming all around the um muddai there
the big meeting house there and
um you know there'd be these beautiful
uh elderly women and that'll be you know
weaving so they'll be sitting behind the
monitor with nikki just quietly weaving
and and it was so great to be part of
that community i suppose again it's it's
that um
you know you feel uh comfortable because
you're you're part of
um it's culture you know it was my
culture so i felt really
at home and i and a and yeah it was it
was
it's just grown and grown i think you
know tiger's had a really big
um he's played a very big part in that
and and us being very present
yeah i believe boy was the first thing i
saw you credited as acting coach on so
did tyka have anything to do with that
yeah yeah he
um his amazing acting coach that he
uses he used to use all the time
i mean he had him he hadn't made that
much but um
lauren taylor she was not available
and she i mean lauren is a really great
action coach she's a director
as well um so doesn't do coaching as
much with
like like myself i try not to do it as
much i'll only do it for taika
um but yeah he she was unable to do the
job
and i had already got the role of auntie
gracie in that film
and um that they would
yeah i was just sort of a logical person
because i had done teaching i
taught uh young kids um quite a lot over
the years
and so in terms of uh theater
and drama so i i guess i seem like an
obvious choice
but yeah i re i didn't i felt like i was
way
out of my comfort zone
i was also um this chaperone so we all
stay together we've got these really big
uh
meeting houses um over here in our at
our culture where our
tribes um and uh sub tribes
um you know are sort of focused um
anyway we me and the kids all stayed in
this big
in these in this big meeting house which
is taika's um
tribes uh meeting house so
yeah it was a really intense job so i do
my
you know i was like playing my character
and coaching the
kids um and then spending the night with
them as well
it sounds like a really beautiful
experience and special way to make uh to
make a project though i love hearing
this
oh yeah oh yeah it's very much out and
keeping with our culture
you know like we so these big meeting
houses we you know we
we all sleep together on them you know
we've all got our
a single mattress and we we sleep with
the photos of our ancestors
and the carved um ancestors as well
so it's it is very it's very
special and very much in keeping with
our culture that that was the way
it was done with it with the kids on boy
but man i was so exhausted